qui avait un doute là-dessus des
mystérieux donc j'étais la fille de
Gainsbourg peut-être et moi le jour de
sa mort je suis allée enfin j'étais je
suis allée à l'école et c'est toute la
cour qui courait je me rappellerai
toujours genre du ronronnement de ton
père il est mort ton père il est mort
ton père il est mort
de début évidemment à votre image un peu
cocasse loup est-ce que vous aviez
l'impression d'avoir la même enfance que
tous les copains de classe ou est-ce que
vous sentiez quand même c'était
différent
mais les enfants c'est terriblement
méchant quoi c'est les gens se rendent
pas compte à quel point ils sont
méchants quoi et
petite ça allait je crois 5 6 enfin je
pète la gueule aux enfants de mon école
petit garçon manqué parce que seul moyen
de se défendre quoi c'était de la
jalousie c'était quoi
avec nous un jour ça va deux jours ça va
et après toute sa scolarité on commence
à enlever quoi c'est ouais tu peux pas
jouer avec eux et en plus avec mon nom
vu que je m'appelais lou j'arrivais dans
un cours et il y avait tous les élèves
qui se cachaient derrière les arbres on
disant faut pas qu'on approche c'est un
loup elle va nous manger en plus c'est
la petite gêne Birkin et sa mère elle
faisait des photos de nu avant etc je te
jure et tout ça alors les enfants ils
parlent pas quand il dit c'est le
contraire de ce que disait Julie et qui
avait l'impression que tout le monde si
vous voulez être pote avec elle mais par
intérêt en fait
c'est nourri par les parents tu vois et
la plupart des enfants d'acteurs sont
dans les écoles privées et moi et mes
parents ont eu raison de se dire tu vois
on va pas la séparer encore plus donc
j'étais en public moi et lycée public je
veux dire toutes les mecs dans la classe
et fils d'ouvriers ou pas et de savoir
que tu es fidèles et que et que tu es
avec eux dans la classe il supporte pas
quoi et après tu grandis et à 9 ans il y
a Serge qui est mort mon grand-père de
jour après et là tout le monde croyait
que c'était mon père quoi vu qu'on
n'avait pas fait de photos en disant qui
j'étais il y avait un doute là-dessus
c'était mystérieux donc j'étais la fille
de Gainsbourg peut-être et moi le jour
de sa mort je suis allée enfin j'étais
chez je suis allée à l'école
et c'est toute la cour qui courait je me
rappellerai toujours genre du
ronronnement de ton père il est mort ton
père il est mort ton père il est mort et
toute une école qui vous dit ça mais ça
sert à quoi c'est pour rien mais c'est
juste voilà c'est dans les journaux on
le voit partout à la télé sa copine de
classe elle est un peu dans cette
histoire-là vu qu'elle est de la famille
on la voit un peu à la télé toute triste
parce que le grand père est mort parce
qu'il y a des connards de paparazzi qui
viennent prendre des photos et voilà ça
va vite et alors après on s'échappe de
ça on se coupe les cheveux on se fait
passer pour un garçon et un moment faut
revenir quoi et on revient à Duruy en se
disant voilà ça va aller mieux
maintenant les enfants c'était des
boules héros maintenant ils vont grandir
on arrive à Duruy et on se fait tabasser
pour prendre le carnet correspondance
pour voir si la signature c'est bien de
dire Jane Birkin ou pas quoi c'est même
les adultes c'est ça que vous voulez
dire mais les profs vous savez en
sixième on te fait remplir une liste
quoi dans du Père Noël etc et les profs
ils se baladent dans les rangs quand il
voit et moi chaque fois c'était genre
discrètement
tu regardes genre quoi votre mère c'est
une bière King était là
[Musique]